let's just bring you some breaking news
we're getting from the crown prosecution
service concerning Sharon bishniewsky
who was killed in 2005. the crown
prosecution Services just said that
piran Dieter Khan who is 74 has been
extradited from Pakistan and charged
with the murder of PC Sharon bijniewski
um chambrushniewsky and her colleague
had responded to reports that an attack
alarm had been activated at a travel
agent on Morley Street in Bradford but
on arrival the officers encountered
three men who had robbed the agent of
five thousand pounds too armed with a
gun another with a knife and one of the
gunman fired at the two offices
immediately at Point Blank Range fatally
wounding Sharon brzniewsky in the chest
and also hitting her colleague Theresa
Milburn who was seriously injured in the
same incident and close circuit
television cameras tracked a car rushing
from the scene and used an automatic
number plate recognition system to trace
its owners that led to six suspects
being arrested another suspect was
arrested in Pakistan more than 14 years
later no word if that is pirandita Khan
but certainly the 74 year old has been
extradited from Pakistan and charged
with the murder of PC Sharon bizniewsky
as I said she was killed in Bradford in
2005.